I don't really care so much about the
revenue on YouTube we've talked about
this but once we were demonetizing that
was a Vox apocalypse
um they stopped counting our subscribers
so the number would be about 12 to 15
million subscribers in the main Channel
and what we had was for years I was
monetized uh the channel we were gaining
between 120 to 250 000 subscribers every
single month I think our lowest month in
that period was 80 and our highest might
have been close to like 300. then we
worked in a month in a month yeah every
and every month was over 100 something
thousand the average was yeah then we
were demonetized the Vox apocalypse
because they couldn't remove us because
we didn't violate any policies yeah
right you see Susan wojcicki who was
talking at the recode conference saying
like sorry it's not really hate speech
but we'll create a new rule of
borderline content so the second word
you monetized boom we were down to 10
000 at most thirty thousand subscribers
a month
[Music]
thank you